benvenuti solida stories oggi proverò il
trucchetti per nascondere gli snack e
dolci pop corn al cinema senza essere
scoperti dal controllore ci sono infatti
tantissimi trucchetti youtube dal canale
one free gote un trumeau file beans
kraft che fanno vedere come nascondere
gli snack al cinema senza essere
scoperti e sarà anche un controllore
molto cattivo e attento
quindi dovrò stare molto attenta a non
farmi scoprire ci saranno quattro round
se vinco più di due round avrò vinto la
challenge
se invece il controllore mi scopro per
più di due round avrò perso la soul nel
dividere to finance mondo alsistem
sapete benissimo che non posso tenere
gli specchi in giro per casa altrimenti
vitale di mangerebbe tutti quindi questo
il mio nascondiglio segreto guardate
vedete questo guardate io ho preso uno
scompartimento segreto in cui nascondo
guardati un po corner a volontari e
merendine patatine il flag e proverò a
nasconderli senza farmi vedere dal
controllore
ma voi mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace se questo video raggiungi 20 mila
mi piace ci sarà una seconda parte in
cui dovrò nuovamente a dare a nascondere
gli snack senza farmi scoprire dal
controllore ma provando nuove tecniche e
trucchetti anzi consigliatemi pure voi i
vostri trucchetti su come nascondere gli
snack zone con belle e se non mi seguite
ancora su instagram andati a seguirmi
nome habitat doris e se volete
seguitemi anche su tik tok ma ora
iniziamo subito con il primo truccare il
primo trucchetto utilizzerò questa una
cloche praticamente la metterò qua nella
pancia così sembrerà che sono incinta ma
in realtà fa dentro ci saranno un sacco
di snack nasco spero che funzioni
proviamo subito evitiamo purtroppo però
che the closet a questo coso qua così
sembra che ho tipo un ombelico gigabyte
ogier ecco cosa guardate con disney con
messico e dentro la proviamo a metterla
nella fase speriamo che non cadano
vediamo se funziona perché i ragazzi
funziona perché gli snack sono qua
dentro e non cadono l'unico problema è
appunto che c'è questo cosa quale sembra
che un ombelico seagal detto guardate
che il controllore non se ne accorga
proprio per questo oppure provò a
toglierlo questo ombelico vediamo se si
toglie forse si trova di guardarsi
esistono svitato
ho tolte l'ombelico ma s'è tolta solo
questa pallina e rimane questo caso
vediamo se si vede beh dai si vede un
pochettino ma non troppo ora provo ad
andare al cinema sperando che il
controllore non se ne accorga
quello laggiù e il controllore lui
controllerà se ho qualche snack nascosto
addosso insieme se riusciamo a vincere
questo primo turno interessanti questi
film e devo andare sì ma ciao mi chiamo
dove lo metto a cui timore ecco la
francia ma chi no per di una vigna
preordinerà come uso deve essere caduto
dalla mia
non so a qualcuno che c'era prima ok
parlano sì sì sì siamo riusciti per il
primo trucchetto
guardate un po kissi miss mac da vedere
durante il film
[Musica]
sono ragazzi prossimo trucchetto in
questa prossimo trucchetto dove
nasconderò gli snack qua nel cappuccio
vero che non si vedono mettendo il
cappuccio così altrimenti dovrò mettere
il cappuccio così in testa ma forse così
si vedano di piu quindi proverò a
lasciare gli snack qui nel cappuccio
tempo non ce ne saranno tantissimi ma
l'importante è riuscire a intrufolarsi
senza che il controllore si scoprono che
è caduti gli snack prova che se sono
riuscita ok
devo solo fare in modo che non si vedano
dai così non si vedono mi sembrano voi
li vedete la con idea
ecco così non dovrebbe accorgersene
forse speriamo speriamo che l'accordo
i biglietti per favore ecco qua
grazie la sala del numero 4 anche questa
è che cosa alla pietro mi faccia
controllare per favore
[Musica]
che cosa trasfondendo signorina meno
male perché molto signorini non signora
come prima molto bene se non sta
nascondendo niente allora si mette anche
accuccia per favore ok cosa sia accaduto
lì per terra che tutto dal soffitto
l'ho visto che cadevano il suo cappuccio
tutto sequestrato poi entrare a vedere
il film ma senza bevande senza cibo sono
sequestrati subito regia tomo di questi
rimangono un fa essere rimasto qualcuno
no non è rimasto niente ma poi lui cosa
ne fa degli snack una volta che li
sequestra prossimo trucchetto dove
nasconderò gli snack questa volta allora
io porterò con me questo pupa cento
pinter niente dicendo questo bel mio
pupazzo che mi fa sempre compagnia
quando vado al cinema ma in realtà è uno
scompartimento segreta sotto questo
pupazzo di una zip e qua c'è una tasca
per nascondere qualcosa e noi ovviamente
nasconderemo degli snack non è molto
grande e vediamo cosa ci sta dentro
proviamo a mettere un po di snack
allora vediamo se esista una coca cola
andrò non ci sto
variamo un pacco di patatine ok forse il
pacco di patatine ci sta ma poi non si
sa nient'altro prova ad aggiungere
questo dolcetto quanto potrei aggiungere
a raggiungere questa barretta basta su
esplodendo meglio chiuderlo dobbiamo
riuscire a chiuderlo bene altrimenti se
ne accorgerà ecco patto lo richiese con
la zip
speriamo che non se ne accorga facciamo
finta di niente
speriamo di riuscire a passare con il
nostro pupazzo pieno di snack prego
favorisca quello gallimard
ma no questo è il mio pupazzo aiuto
abbiamo il biglietto a chi ritieni
grazie facciamo incollare e come mai
auto pazzo in mano perché il mio animale
da compagnia
posso controllarlo e in cui si preoccupi
sono non ascolta niente la parola una
piccola infezione o perché mi ha
attaccato il suo gatto
[Musica]
prendiamo a prendere disse un pacco di
patatine una barretta e un altro
dolcetto attivo nascondigli dana troverò
nascondere gli snack dentro a questo che
appello di supermario ho scelto questo
capelli scuri mario perché è molto
grande e qua sopra
e c'è molto spazio quindi dovrei
riuscire a farci stare un bel po di né
guardate ho anche preso questi mini
contenitori di pop corn quando sono
carini
guardate che carina la via bigny
confezioni di pop corn se essendo così
piccola non si accorgerà che l'alto
nascondendo secondo voi
devo smetterla di mangiare devo
sbrigarmi riempie il nostro appello
allorché così missione mettiamo un
estate al limone si lo so che siete
quasi tutti i team pes che qua
ok prima un pacco di patatine luna
valentina un altro pacco di patatine i
pop corn ugo paura che si rovesceranno
qua dentro ma proviamo a metterli lo
stesso abbiamo mettere il cappello
adesso vediamo
juan non è molto stabile
no devo togliere il tè altrimenti troppo
pesante uffa devo darle un po ok ora è
molto più leggero in un cane
come non detto che così non dovrebbe
cadere ma devo stare molto attenta ai
movimenti che pazzo altrimenti che ha
del tutto il controllo rosa ne accorgerà
andiamo
[Musica]
che permette volevo solo un consiglio su
cui film vedere molto bene per
interessata a questo visto che lo notava
sì questo karate gogh che cos'è
si tratta di un cane che dopo essere
stato abolito da altri cani decide di
prendere delle lezioni di karate e che
si rivolge ad un anziano maestro per
insegnarli l'altra l'arte del karate
ecco perché karate do
inezie nell'inno balboa berlino balboa
questo è un famosissimo film dove recita
il famosissimo attore merlino appunto
lui prende delle lezioni di pugilato
diventerà un bravissimo pugile ma non ti
voglio spolverare altro su questo è ok
allora procediamo voglio vedere karate
doc
magari gli altri metrò un altro giorno
però andiamo ad heinze brighiamo ci vado
a prendere il biglietto lì che poi venga
qui per l'entrata però la perquisizione
dei qualche bello perché cosa c'è di
male nel mio cappello
mi sembra un po sofferto comunque
bisogno da filiere cosa è accaduto del
fratello niente è solo il mio cappello
mio fratello quel cibo non è ammesso le
boe entrare ma senza quel cibo che verrà
sequestrato si va da capello a filo con
il cappello prego si accomodi e anche
questo cibo e sequestrato tutto per
tutto per me gusta il controllore ha
coperto il mio nascondiglio degli snacks
il cappello
noi li ha sequestrati guardate che cosa
gli era rimasto qui i mini pop corn
almeno potrò mangiare il mini pop corn
durante il film certo non sono tanti
sono pochi ma bengasi niente ho fatto
proprio un bel bottino
oh che bello foresi mangia
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete una
seconda parte a 20.000 mi piaci si sarà
la seconda parte fatemi sapere nei
commenti qual è il trucchetto che mi ha
fatto ridere più di tutti a me tutti
forse quando mi è caduto lo snack dalla
pace è stato super divertente ora vi
lascio qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao